this plan bring in a lot of mixed
emotions for parents some are
rejoicing others a little bit concerned
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to some and sally they are feeling
excited
and nervous at the same time
brian after speaking to parents some
tell me they are extremely excited they
cannot wait for their kids to come back
into the classroom as for others say it
won't be happening on their end
and some tell me they're stuck in the
middle again i'm just really
excited it's time to get back to normal
christian nigro is a ccsd teacher but
also a parent of a kindergarten student
she is excited about the reopening plan
to be quite honest
i have been looking forward to this date
because i know
as a teacher as well as a parent
i see these poor kids in the way that
they struggle this school year
[ __ ] hopes that by putting kids back
into the classroom that will boost their
academic confidence
we need to be able to hopefully find
some ways for them to
you know relieve some of that pent-up
excitement
and i'm hoping that we have some good
structured recess
opportunities in place lacey jones has
three kids enrolled in the school
district
a junior ninth and sixth grader it's
crazy because it's kind of a mixed
emotion type of thing
she wasn't sure if they were returned
this year but i do know people
that don't want their kids to go back
yet and i know some parents who have
some major health issues and so
if they were to get sick it would it
would be really detrimental
jones is also concerned about the
teachers
are they planning for like maybe extra
help like extra tutoring help for some
of the kids if the teachers
are overwhelmed i have been talking to
my son tony every single day about what
this is going to look like